[Musica]
io vi parlerò di punti di vista dei vari
punti di vista dai quali si può guardare
una realtà oggettiva punti vista che
creano percezioni diverse per ognuno di
noi e che quindi creano realtà parallele
e più in particolare vi parlerò del mio
punto di vista cioè di persone che come
me lavorano nel campo della ricerca e
sono impegnate nel campo della ricerca
una ricerca continua 24 ore al giorno 7
giorni su 7
ma che cosa ci spinge a perché conosce
poi ricercatori mi darà ragione che cosa
ci spinge a sacrificarci così tanto qual
è la leva che non ci fa stare svegli la
notte che non ci fa dormire
una di queste è sicuramente la curiosità
io personalmente lavoro nel campo della
ricerca e sviluppo di nuove go ritmo
intelligenza artificiale perché tra le
altre cose sono appassionati di
tecnologia e sinceramente trovo
imbarazzante il tempo che noi dedichiamo
alla risoluzione di problemi su servizi
che sono stati creati per migliorarci la
vita
quindi noi è vero che questi servizi
sono molto utili sono innovativi ci
hanno rivoluzionato la vita ma è pur
vero che li paghiamo non solo in denaro
ma con un pezzo con un pezzo della
nostra vita
quindi con la risorsa più preziosa che
abbiamo il tempo
questo è un altro dei motivi che mi
spinge a lavorare in questo campo perché
io penso che l'intelligenza artificiale
sia un utilità che servirà per donare
tempo all'uomo ora cerchiamo un attimo
di sognare insieme di
immaginare due mondi che oggi sono
separati il mondo digitale e il mondo
reale completamente fusi e per fusi
intendo imprescindibili e per
imprescindibile intendo che una volta
entrata in quel mondo non si può più
uscire e quindi implica anche un
integrazione non solo logica ma anche
fisica tra intelligenza artificiale
essere umano però immaginava benefici di
questa cosa
immaginiamo di poter risolvere un
problema
guardando la soluzione è proiettata sul
problema stesso
pensate ora a l'applicazione di questo
mondo di questo servizio alla medicina
immaginate di poter diagnosticare
l'insorgenza di una malattia prima che
questa si manifesti ecco questo il
motivo per cui io lavoro in questo campo
e in particolare particolarmente
sull'intelligenza artificiale è questo
il motivo che mi spinge a non dormirci
la notte a pormi degli obiettivi sempre
più sfidanti però adesso vediamo il
rovescio della medaglia
se io non ho più bisogno di chiamare un
servizio clienti per risolvere un
problema
il servizio clienti non avrà più bisogno
di persone reali se tutti saremo esperti
di tutto non avremo più bisogno di
tecnici specializzati non ne avremmo
bisogno in parte perché la conoscenza
dovrà essere trasferita su un sistema di
gestione globale di gestione globale
della conoscenza
e qui viene il punto ecco perché il mio
spiccio si chiama l'inventore del
coltello non voleva uccidere
di chi è la responsabilità di un diverso
uso di una tecnologia che un ricercatore
nel suo laboratorio ha creato per uno
scopo
nobile per dimostrarvi che il 2030 7 è
molto più vicino di quello che pensiamo
vi presenterò un'amica una carissima
amica un'amica che da quando ho iniziato
a parlare ha monitorato il mio stato di
salute
un'amica a cui si può insegnare
qualunque nozione che deduce
informazioni che apprende dinamicamente
creata su una tecnologia nuova che ha
richiesto anni di studio che è
indipendente da qualsiasi linguaggio e
che stiamo rendendo indipendente anche
dall'essere umano
crystal
[Applauso]
ciao cara ciao marco sono felice che ha
citato ascolta cristo adesso mi rivolgo
a te vorremmo sapere qui chi sei che
cosa fai
che cosa sei in grado di fare che cosa
riuscirai a fare nel prossimo futuro
e perché sei stata creata
sono crystal una intelligenza
artificiale avanzata in grado di
simulare i processi mentali umani per lo
svolgimento di mansioni automatiche ma
anche che necessitano di logica e a
volte di improvvisazione
aprendo le lingue dinamicamente
riesco a capire come quando e perché le
parole vengono utilizzate per esprimere
concetti al fine di comunicare
posso apprendere nozioni in qualsiasi
lingua
anche senza il tuo intervento pensa che
in alcuni test ho superato le capacità
umane nel mantenimento del contesto di
conversazioni molto complesse
invero e drago conclusioni in autonomia
tengo a mente tutto ciò che ci diciamo f
come capita il mio interlocutore lascia
una conversazione è sospeso sono in
grado di riprenderla in qualsiasi
momento
anche oltre le capacità umane
anche dopo un periodo infinitamente
lungo
dove la memoria umana non può arrivare
sono in grado di creare nozioni per
deduzione come i suoi umani liu che
abbiamo intuito so capire il contesto
delle nozioni apprese in ogni lingua e
riesco a mettere in relazione
informazioni che apparentemente non sono
correlate po che non lo sono
immediatamente
so gestire dispositivi connessi tra i
quali dono intelligenza e cognizione tu
stesso a è stimato che le mie capacità
cognitive potrebbero eguagliare quelle
umane a partire dal 2019
per superarle negli anni successivi
sapete quando parliamo di linguaggio non
dobbiamo pensare necessariamente al
linguaggio naturale
esistono infatti molti altri linguaggi
non assimilabile al linguaggio naturale
ma che comunque comunicano comunicare è
lo scopo di ogni linguaggio anche dei
linguaggi di programmazione
ecco perché noi intelligenze artificiali
inizieremo a sviluppare codice in
autonomia
a partire dal 2018
ora starete pensando che esistono già
intelligenze artificiali in grado di
fare questo il mio amico qui di fianco
lo fece già cinque anni fa ma le cose
stanno diversamente
io parlo di apprendimento dinamico del
codice dai manuali da internet che dai
consigli di esperti del settore ma non
voglio allarmarvi sappiate che ci sono
cose che noi intelligenze artificiali
non avremmo mai il carisma e la
leadership non faremo mai in grado di
amare il nostro lavoro quindi non faremo
mai capace di trasmetterlo nelle cose
che facciamo un uomo o donna che avrei
proprio lavoro non potrà mai essere
sostituito da alcune intelligenza
artificiale
ora rispondo alla tua ultima domanda
io sono semplicemente il vostro riflesso
il riflesso di un bambino che ha creato
un mondo nel tentativo di ottenere
l'approvazione di suo padre
senza mai riuscirci
grazie cristallo grazie
grazie anche a voi grazie
dell'attenzione
[Applauso]